[Musique]
charming birds are you need non il parle
aux français oui c'est bon choix
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous bonjour à
tous qu'on rende jeu tu fais là oui je
sais que ça qu'est ce que tu m'as près
pas aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est ça
j'ai déjà vu ça
non tu n'as pas vu ça comment j'ai pas
vu ça à ce que la ja trois bouteilles y
avait eu un bouchon divorce est oui
c'est le grand jeu oui pourquoi tu
trouves que c'est très différent de ce
que tu m'avais montre l'autre jour c'est
c'est très différent pour quoique on ya
quelque chose que je rajoute cette fois
ci mais tu vois tu vas regarde il ya des
petites photos là bas ça en fait des
petits dessins je vais les installer
chez les installe ça c'est toi si je
comprends bien celui-là ça c'est toi
dessinée alors on a planté sur les
bouchons et un petit dessin qui te
représente c'est une magnifique que des
jeux prend bien faudra bref de tous âges
très bien alors là nous avons également
un autre dessin c'est celui de bell bell
qui n'est pas mal non plus nous mettons
en équilibre comme ça c'est très très
bien belles belles et enfin il y à
l'inénarrable l'adorable pouces moussu
que voici enfin je vais écarter à tout
petit peu les bouteilles et je vous
manqués voit maintenant pouces moussu
oui alors moi j'ai appelé ça le jeu de
massacre des quatre amis a alors pour
jouer c'est très simple on prend un
bouchon on prend des bouchons des
bouchons oui si tu veux on se recule et
on joue très exactement comme les jeux
de massacre ça vous a peut-être déjà vu
ça dans les foires affectés ou des
personnages des photos ou bien des
boîtes de conserve et là vous reculez là
je peux pas le faire parce que sinon on
va tout renverser mais on recule on
jette les bouches ans et il s'agit non
pas de faire tomber les petites effigie
personnages et de les faire se balancer
vous souvenez du système d' équilibre
des fourchettes
alors vous pouvez le faire balancer
comme ça en tapant directement avec le
bouchon mais vous ne devez pas les faire
tomber le système
c'est pas mal hein si bien amusant on
pourra peut-être s'exercer assez bien la
forme qu'on voudra et vous savez que ça
peut tout de même se balancer assez
violemment
regardez grâce au fameux équilibre des
fourchettes
voilà bon eh ben c'est très bien je sors
maintenant je sais c'est pas la peine de
me le dire je suis en deuil sinon et là
je le fais fait la grimace
aujourd'hui sera l'équipe j'ai mal
partout ça me fait mal après bangalore
est un nom que je te fasse vraiment une
grille mais alors quel genre une
rigolote
bah vous une rigolote mais je sais pas
moi tiens ça la cip et maintenant ça
c'est pas une grimace s'annoncer naturel
tu veux que je te fasse peut-être je ne
sais pas moi là c'est pas très joli hein
c'est pas faut pas le faire devant
n'importe qui pourrait le faire entre
vous mais pas autrement alors c'est bien
pour te faire plaisir tout en
co-organisation 3 4 6 et le guen le les
laines au qui donnait les heures et
l'aide ne fait jamais ça un pas devant
les parents après j'aurai des histoires
ne me faites pas avoir des histoires
dont le jardin je m'en vais dans le
jardin d'accord d'accord et oui
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
abbas comme tron ah bon le point commun
de la région du sud alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors on fera qu'on peut la
team fabrice le voilà les bat à
c'est pas de plaisanter un jésus
maintenant d'être extrêmement sérieux
attentifs vous aussi d'ailleurs vous
devez être sérieux et attentif puisque
vous participez au jeu et que vous devez
trouver quel est le point commun entre
les trois personnages ou les trois
hommes jolie trois choses sont
représentés partout quand belles belles
et pousse mossu mes enfants je suis à
vous comme ans
ça c'est le gong du départ et bien moi
je suis un pic à 1 1 me cup est à dire
que je me trompe je suis beaucoup mieux
qu'un big je suis qu'attendent comme on
dit maintenant une chaîne stéréo à la
salle alors je possède est enceinte des
manettes des cadres entre les tas de
petits signaux lumineux je démarre je
m'arrête automatiquement et toi je peux
être très doux faire beaucoup de bruit
je suis même stéréophonique 1 c'est vous
dire oui cette fois c'était un phonique
alors à moi alors eh bien moi cela va
vous paraître curieux je suis un veston
d'hommes pour une personne aussi
féminine que ma vie d'amour ça surprend
et je suis même tous les vestons
d'hommes se comporte lité léger sans
doublure aux couleurs claires se
comporte l'hiver en bon l'ena gp où je
vais même aller plus loin je peux être
un pardessus un gilet on a permis à
bûches qu'ils ont fait toutes sortes de
vêtements mais pas une chaussette à
l'eau claire
quoi que je suis sur la voie mais
l'important la version 2 à moi alors
alors moi j'ai pas ce que j'ai mais j'ai
pas ce qui m'arrive je suis je suis
malade je ne sais pas si j'ai mangé
quelque chose de mauvais ou si j'ai été
piqué par des moustiques mais mais je me
gratte cheveux gratuits
j'ai l'impression que je suis
complètement défiguré je n'ai pas fermé
l'oeil de la nuit
je pensais qu'avec la rosée de ce matin
ça allait s'arranger ce pauvre va pas du
tout alors tu vois fabrici c'était
gentil là tu tu me gratter un peu là un
peu sur le côté
oui la ola au oui oh oui ça va très bien
merci
je crois je crois pouvoir dire quand je
suis sur la voie à
aussi j'avais trouvé suivez-moi bien une
ces lots de fidélité pour tous quand bon
pour belbel mois nous avons dit un
costume d'homme ou un pardessus oui oui
horrible
quant à ce pauvre pouces mousse ou alors
il est malade il se gratte pas haut et
howie alors là tout de même cela vous
mettre sur la voie je le dis vous avez
tous les toits des boutons des boutons à
brave rôle et la fidélité vous très
attendu dont le costume est bon oui oui
quand ils viennent à jamais fiers de toi
fabrice un passage vont bien ah oui
c'est bien ça y est mais au moment où
elle veut s'en aller mais oui mais tu
sais pourquoi je me voyais pas aller
fallu racler territoire a tout bon à
l'arrêt à la pousse moussu vous faire
son petit jeu riche et à moi maintenant
un petit jeu là oui c'est un bois matin
comme d'habitude et oui et oui je me
décris oui mais alors allons-y
cette semaine c'est un mot de onze
lettres y arrivons je me demande si tôt
tableau va être assez grand je me
débrouille et oui alors je commence par
quelle lettre est battue commence par la
lettre h
h très bien h voilà voilà
alors tu fais neuf petits traits qui
remplace de lettres exactement 3 4 5 6 7
8 et 9
voilà oui et alors la dernière lettre
fait c'est un air voilà voilà à sa bonne
figure joli à jeudi alors c'est un
animal
ah ah non non non c'est pas un animal ça
m'embête c'est pas un homme célèbre
alors je prends donc celle que par une
femme célèbre non plus n'ont plus qu'une
couleur une fois une couleur oh non
les fruits n'ont plus rien de fleurs non
non pas une plante non qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'était il reste pas grand
chose à ses toiles et méfiance est pas
une plante est pas un fruit c'est pas
c'est un métal non non non non non non
non c'est pas un métal
c'est cet endroit non non c'est sa vie
bah oui ça vit ça respire
ah bah oui bien sûr me disent tu es pas
un animal c'était pas un homme s'était
pas une femme
aaaaah je n'ai jamais dit que c'était
pas un homme william sheller hommes
célèbres date il aime non c'est un homme
alors oui c'est top c'est un homme oui
empathie dont alors là tu m'étonnes
c'est un homme rim est un homme que je
connais non tu te connais tu l'as vu
déjà tu en as déjà vu
j'en ai messieurs qui font ça certaines
espèces d'hommes d'animer me dis tiens à
ce sens c'est un homme qu un métier un
métier bien sûr c'est donc en fait un
métier c'est un homme camédia c'est un
métier d'artisan sur veut arrêter
artistique
non non non non non pas du tout non
c'était un métier très utile en donne
moi une lettre un abat voilà je vais te
donner la cinquième l'aide si tu veux
toi tu penses que la cinquième lettre
c'est ainsi alors deux trois quatre cinq
ici c'est ainsi qu'est ce que ça peut
être que ça ça il fait de la musique non
nom et prénom car ce qu'il est il
s'occupe de suivant il vend quelque
chose enfin il peut il peut il peut
vendre le rythme tout kung fu le produit
son travail ils sont là ils travaillent
pas tout seul je peux dire qu'ils
travaillent pas travailler un instrument
non un outil non plus non plus mais
c'est très très dangereux ce qui fait
enfin c'est assez dangereux quand même
c'est dangereux
lui dit habitué il a l'habitude alors
envisager l'achat des vêtements pour ça
et là où il avait su créé dans les
vêtements il se met des gants et puis
ça met des gants oui puis fais attention
il se met aussi quelque chose sur la
tête sur la figure il se protège le
visage enfin vous avez trouvé
fais moi c'est tout chaud alors
aujourd'hui sont en train de m'avoir si
je trouve pas je donne ma langue au chat
quand même alors elle devrait trouver un
nom il met des gants il fait très
attention
bon dieu protège son visage à aca grille
à genève est ce que c'est un abus oui
oui oui oui du vitrail dans les champs
oui ça y est maintenant je crois que je
vois mais ça peut pas aller parce qu'un
h là c'est pas un apiculteur et ben
voilà c'est vrai en asturies trouver
quand même un à l'apiculteur un
apiculteur un apiculteur et tu écris
apiculteurs bas
h api cu lt eur6 bien comme exemple pour
les jeunes qui nous écoute je veux dire
c'est leur sert c'est intéressant à baby
culte r&d et il a c est l apiculteur
voilà comment ça fait deux ici à new
york wata leur apiculteur tout ou alors
je vais te dire une chose
ça c'est très mauvais oeil à bohain
alors franchement c'est mauvais tu sais
comment on écrit apiculteurs maintenant
pouces moussu oui je tombe vous aviez
bien entendu comme un éditeur au pays
c'est ul ter voilà ce qu'il fait je te
remercie fabrice touléma appris comment
s'écrivait apiculteurs bah ouais ouais
bah écoute moi oui écoute-moi fabrice
peut-être apprendre quelque chose bien
sûr les abeilles oui tu crois qu'elle
serve sur toi à produire du miel à
eybens et ben ce n'est pas tout et comme
elles passent leur temps à se promener
de fleur en fleur et surtout printemps
elle transporte des petites graines dans
toute la région qu'elle habite et grâce
à elle les fleurs et les plantes se
reproduise en bien plus grand nombre on
a là
en somme en somme elles font un travail
de jardinier pratiquement et louis prat
et booba merci pour ces précisions à
baloche dormir si toi tu vas voir c'est
bien pour leurs graffs c'est un échange
de bons procédés exactement rue tout
cancan oui alors c'est une chanson dans
le coeur maintenant tu vas voir c'est
vrai oui déçu oui c'est ma belle belle
belle belle c'est ma belle bella mois et
la charité
allons-y
[Musique]
un pic su profiter du fait qu'ils ne
suis qu'un petit sucre depuis à moi est
ce qu un communiqué
[Musique]
mais tu swing dire fabrice plaît je dis
1 bat without you go qu'est ce que tu
racontes tu parles chinois mec non
écoute tu viens de me poser une question
l'armée tu m'as dit veux-tu une tasse de
thé c'est bien ce que j'ai cru
comprendre alors je t'ai répondu je
revienne une tasse de thé lécheur mais
sans se croire bravo quel indice on vise
à milan mais quel axe aux usa est
compréhensible
mon pauvre fabrice et une bafouille
c'est embêtant dans le métier du fait
apprendre à parler une langue
correctement prises il faut aller dans
le pays écoute moi qui prends en de la
graine à bas coût avec kamov qui dira
tout cancan who have
que peuvent-ils dire pouce moussy mais
mes vestes mais qu'est ce que tu dis
quoi voulez-vous
mais qu'est ce que c'est jelly fait chez
qui j'habitais lorsque j'étais à londres
mais charmante langlès typique
ravissante des yeux noirs [ __ ] en paix
là n'est pas la question
jennifer disait m'a appris à faire cette
boisson spécifiquement but unique
il me faut de l'eau bouillante dans le
bouillant allons faire boire de l'eau
bouillante non match prévient je ne bois
que de la rosée à un bol chaque matin
oui lieu avec kamov ya les voyages
il n'y a rien de tel pour enrichir à
l'esprit on prend être un bateau on
débarque sur une terre inconnue
mystérieuse dont les habitants
instantanément vous étonnent par leur
physionomie par leurs moeurs
tous ces petits homme brun aux yeux
[ __ ] qui vous demande vous avoue que
peuvent-ils annoncé en et puis alors il
ya ces sages tous ces sages que l'on
rencontre dans des forêts de sapins
oui des sages fabrice oui dernière du
jamais vu là bas c'est à dire que j'ai
vu des singes mais dans les forêts de
sapins en bleu perdu alors c'est parce
que tu ne marche pas toujours en vêtir
moi je suis une écologiste j'aime les
longues promenades en angleterre j'ai
couru les compagnies les bois en quête
de paysages nouveaux la curiosité
d'esprit est une forme d'intelligence
j'ai longuement discuté avec les
indigènes je me suis passionné pour
leurs problèmes si vous connaissiez les
soucis des pêcheurs de sardines de
perles au douar à propos de perles
demont avait donné une en souvenir mais
qu'est-ce que j'en ai fait moi ou les
chemises les prises pour un support
jolie mise dans ma cup of tea escale à
fabas qui expédia et ben et ba et ba
belles belles mais qu'est ce qu'un au
revoir au revoir
ravi de te soigner ah non mais vous
savez moi je me demande si belle baie
n'est pas un petit peu comme ça parce
que alors son histoire de voyage à
londres avec sa tasse de thé trop gras
d'abord moi je crois que les hommes les
anglais dirais plutôt would you like que
peuvent-ils couteau que will you have un
jeu en anglais je pense que ça se dirait
plutôt comme ça tu vois et puis ensuite
l'histoire des yeux [ __ ]
vous avez déjà vu beaucoup d'anglais
avec les yeux [ __ ] et qu'est ce que tu
a relevé encore te quand est ce que tu
as été au moins attentifs oui bien sûr
alors qu'est ce que tu a relevé encore
qui n'avait de tant de choses auxquelles
je ne crois guère
oui alors quoi par exemple de dire oui
il visage
les visages comment les singes par
exemple dix villages de sages des
visages de tous âges dans des forêts
deux des forêts redd et coûte rien du
tout dans des forêts de pins de leur dû
parfaitement peuvent stationner
évidemment ne s'arrache pas là je vais
te dire des singes dans des forêts de
pins en angleterre alors elle a
peut-être vu ça au zoo de londres mais
certainement pas dans l'effort et
anglaise encore d'étape d'état allait
pas du tout et j'ai je te dirai encore
plein d'erreurs
we watched le temps mais le temps me
ment avery c'est ça oui tu préfère dire
ça pour je ne te demande pas exactement
quoi parce que je sais que
tu n'écoutes pas toujours très
attentivement parfois je peux somnoler
oui ça c'est époustouflant général qui
somnole bien terminé avec le petit jeu
de massacre que tu nous a préparés au
oui allons nous massacrer qu'il va
tomber sacre en premier toi tu le
mériterait tout quand c'est peut-être ce
que je vais faire d'ailleurs je vous
rappelle que c'est tout simple tout
simple trois bouteilles des fourchettes
piqué dans des bouchons les effigies de
toucan de bell bell de pouce moussu sans
problème voilà pouces mais aussi par
exemple mais vous pouvez remplacer
avantageusement ses effigies par deux
autres seul de vos petits camarades ou
celle de vos professeurs enfin peut-être
pas ça leur ferait pas plaisir et pour
jouer simple avec un des bouchons vous
mettez à un ou deux mètres et vous
essayez non pas de les faire tomber mais
de les faire bouger simplement car vous
savez qu'avec les fourchettes placé
comme cela on obtient un équilibre assez
remarquable vous voyez ça tient j'espère
que vous réussirez réaliser sa très
facilement et je vous souhaite de vous
amuser avec vos petits copains
à ce jeu là et à d'autres à ce que vous
avions déjà montré
on va à tous et à très bientôt en avant
pour le massacre
[Musique]